if you have three price points small  medium large where you move the middle  will dictate how many of them you sell  even if you keep the small and the large  at the same price for example let's say  that we've got five dollars and ten  dollars as these things if i put the  middle very very close to the top the  top one will look like a steel compared  to the middle because it's only 10 more  and i might get a lot more stuff and so  if i wanted to sell more larges i would  push the medium right next to it and  make it seem like a no-brainer upsell  psychologically on the flip side if i  wanted to sell more of the middle one i  would expand the distance between the  large and the middle and so that this  one would look like the more reasonable  option compared to the premium price you  should always have a very expensive  thing to sell because you can drive more  sales to the middle while also allowing  people who want to spend the money to go  buy the super expensive thing